we posted a poll on our youtube
community tab
and the question was do you trust film
distributors so the poll received about
8 000 or so votes
and 85 percent of those polled said they
do not
trust distributors um now we didn't ask
them in what capacity they've dealt with
them
where do you think this negative
reputation stems from
it all goes to the the failure rate
of films
and i think that
um
i think some distributors oversell
what will happen
to films in order to get them
um not all but some do
i think it goes to expectations of just
getting a distribution deal and thinking
hey i'm done
it's going to make make money i think
that's part of it
um
i think it's frustrating to have
um
gatekeepers
to the public you know there's there
there's so many things coming out of a
dollar before it gets to you
um as the filmmaker
because you know someone buys the film
on itunes um
itunes is taking 30 percent
right that's 70 is going to your
distributor your distributor is taking
25
and costs so when they get by costs then
they're paying you at that point right
so
there's there's a lot of international
sales
your international sales company is
taking 20 percent
they're putting it with a distributor
overseas is going to take their
percentage that distributor is putting
on a digital platform that's gonna put
it and make money in germany or wherever
so there's three steps before it gets
gets
to you
um
so
you know if it were the case that
and it is the case that you know people
could go and put film you do have the
ability to go put the film
on digital platforms yourself
so um
there are labs that have kind of
aggregator
um
kind of call themselves aggregators
although i think the word aggregator is
kind of a strange word for it but
all they really do is facilitating
placing the film on
amazon itunes google play etc
um and there
you're paying them the cost of encoding
the film for the platform
but they're not taking the percentage at
all so you're you know itunes is taking
30 and you're getting 70
um
the reason
why and now maybe some films should do
that
because
they could just
you know it's a small film and they can
push people to
watch on itunes and then they get what
they
they reap what they sew
um
the reason people go to distributors as
opposed to
doing it themselves is distributors can
get to more platforms than these labs
can
um there are some platforms that require
a pitch
so to get a film on
um in demand directv dish
etc you need someone to go and pitch the
movie to them
and then
when it comes out on itunes and amazon
cetera it's going to be the release date
is going to be the same for those
platforms
in addition
these distributors have relationships
with
streaming companies like netflix and
hulu and hbo
so once they have the film in the
transactional vod world
they're then going to go try to make
that sell if you go put your film on
itunes you can't there's just no way to
get into netflix at that point even i
can't go to netflix i i can go to
netflix originals division as a producer
rep but i can't go to them in a
distributor position of where it is
after it's been on transactional for a
while
so
if we lived in a world where all these
platforms
were open to filmmakers going there
that's what we would do
and i would i would become a marketing
expert instead i would
help people with marketing and just say
hey let's just go put in these platforms
but there are gatekeepers to those
platforms where people have those
relationships and that's the reason we
have to use them
um
and then there are some people that
treat that space
honorably and
[Music]
are respectful of the fact they got
lucky enough to be in such a position to
be the gateway for other people's
content
and treat their filmmakers well and
explain everything to them and try to do
the best and then there are some that
really just take it and never call you
back
and
that's that's for you know i think it
kind of goes back to communication i
think at the end of the day
there's just if if distributors did a
better job of communicating
on the front end
what's going to happen what the what you
know what's likely
what's you know realistically
the a medium outcome or the best outcome
um and in addition
we're a little bit more open
as filmmakers came back to them with
questions about how it's going
and explain what you know why they were
doing what they were doing i think if
they were better at that in general
that poll number would be a little bit
better
um
although i think the
the main reason for it is just most
films fail
and
and therefore who we're gonna blame
i'm not gonna blame my movie my movie is
perfect right like i it's my baby
um and the person who adopted my baby is
not raising it properly
you know um
and uh
but um
but yeah i think um
but that's hard that's hard for them to
do it's you know it's
in the deal you're dealing with
corporations
and distributors are not individuals
and so you've got you know the director
of acquisitions the director of sales
the director of delivery
the cfo the accounting department
and they all have their own lanes of
what they kind of deal with and as the
filmmaker like oh so who do i talk to
about the fact that this doesn't look
right or i want i don't you know amazon
my poster on amazon looks a little weird
or whatever and sometimes it's hard to
navigate because not all companies have
a front person it's just like you know
kind of the
the go-to for the client to say okay you
got this problem you know talk to this
person
um i think part of this is like
economics like they just don't have the
bandwidth to have that many employees at
the end of the day
and
take the you know they they do the math
of like we need to take this number of
films we can make this amount of money
and so we've got to
you know stretch our employees to do
this number of jobs and they're just not
going to get
royal treatment like they want
and then there's also the the sort of
thought of that you know filmmakers are
artists and their work is kind of never
done so they're probably tweaking the
poster art maybe the log line different
things and then they're making all these
changes and submitting it and then
you're dealing with business people who
don't have the time maybe to to handhold
all these subsequent you know i mean i'm
sure that probably happens a little bit
and then they feel like they're being
ignored and maybe in some cases they are
being ignored and others it's just their
demands are so high
yeah um
yeah i don't know if i i don't see a lot
of people still tinkering after the fact
it's usually
the t it's usually the case that they
have to at some point they have to you
know okay i'm done
and let it and let it go creatively at
least
in terms of log line or trailer
or things like that i don't see a lot of
people where i see it breaking down is
much more
in terms of like well what's happening
you're like are you trying to sell
netflix
like i haven't heard
um anything and most distributors just
don't
care about communicating that
they don't really they feel like you
know we're doing our job we're going to
pay you
what you do
but we don't need to explain to you what
we're saying to netflix
or
when we're going to talk to netflix
or or any of that
i just feel like
distributors probably
don't feel like they have the time
in a day to talk to all their filmmakers
about all the intricacies of everything
they do
is my
best guess
best guess from being on the outside
looking in
a lot
but never really being in
at the same time
what type of accounting practices should
a filmmaker expect when working with a
distributor
so overwhelmingly most distributors
offer quarterly accountings
um
and that's that's pretty standard to at
least get two or three years of
quarterly
and then
um
and then turns to biannual after that or
annual sometimes
and that's when your most of your
revenue is gonna that's what it really
counts the most um
the frustrating thing with accounting
is that distributors are on accounting
terms as well with the platforms
so a lot of times people get their first
quarter statement and they're ready you
know okay let's see how we did and it's
not there's not much there
and that's partly because
when i go and buy a film on amazon
amazon keeps that money for 90 days
before it hits the bank account of your
distributor
and so
if it's march and i paid for it uh in
march
um
it's not going to hit
um
the distributor until
june
and that's the second quarter so even
though someone paid for something in the
first quarter
the streamer didn't get it until the
second quarter and so that's when
they're going to account for it
usually anywhere from 30 to 90 days
after the quarter
so it takes a long time for stuff to
come in
and that's frustrating
i wish it was more
i wish it was unfortunately
that's what makes it hard to do anything
in social media to try and help the
cause because you can if you buy ads and
stuff for lots of products out there you
can kind of see what it does for you
right and if you spend you know
ten thousand dollars on facebook ads you
can see what the return is on whatever
you're selling pretty quickly because
you're the one selling it
but in film you you do the advertising
and you're waiting
uh
six months
to find out whether
amazon anybody bought the film on amazon
and then you're past really the period
so that's makes the whole business so
hard because you just don't the
companies that dominate the space in
terms of where people buy movies
um
can can dictate the terms of how they
account
even to the distributors
so you're saying that a filmmaker
reasonably
most contracts would say
every quarter you're getting a statement
for two years and then after that it's
bi-annually and then annually yeah
okay so then if they have nine years
then toward the latter end of it they're
going to be getting yearly statements
correct
and some it depends on the distributor
because some distributors
are more amenable to changing their
basic terms than others so it kind of
depends but
um some distributors will say well
eventually if we if we don't collect
anything we're not going to account
so there's zero coming in
there's no reason to send you a piece of
paper that says zero came in
sometimes we try to add language that
says you're going to counterbus
regardless because i want you to be
accountable per se
so it can depend on the distributor